Hello and welcome the fire of learning the Huizar ski on Yola,
known as the Polish winged Huizar is in English.
We're one of the most elite and important groups of cavalry within the Polish
army for over 200 years.
The image which defines them of course,
were the large wings made from the feathers of ostriches eagles are swans,
which are either attached to the backs of their armor or to their horses
saddles,
but there was much more to these,
his ours than just show.
They were in fact some of the most fearsome and successful soldiers in history.
The origins of Huizar than general dates back to the 15th century when Serbian
Horseman Leaving Their Homeland After Ottoman conquest were recruited into
Hungarian armies as Light Cavalry with the success of these units to Polish,
we're quick to follow with the first Polish reserve.
Ours made of Serbian mercenary as well being around definitely by the year 1500
but most likely a little earlier throughout the course of the 16th century,
the WHO's ours turned from a mercenary light cavalry into a heavier elite
cavalry made up of recruits from the Polish upper classes.
One of their first great victories was at the battle of [inaudible] in which the
Polish wing to czar is chased.
The revolting soldiers from the city of Danzig all the way to the city gates
killing over 4,000 men while losing less than 100 the angels of death,
we're just beginning for over a century.
They would rarely lose and we're often the deciding factor in many of the
battles in which they fought battles such as Virginia,
cocaine,
housing Ketchem to Chana levophed and the infamous battle of Vienna.
They were shocked troops,
meaning they were specialized troops trained to lead a tax and penetrate enemy
lines at the battle of clue Shino.
They defeated the Russians decisively despite being out in number five to one at
coke and housing.
The polls defeated as Swedish losing 200 and killing over 2000 and at the battle
of Vienna 3000 wing to czars took part and the largest cavalry charge in history
along with 15,000 Holly Romans under the command of the Polish King John
Sobieski.
The third this charge would route the demoralized and exhausted Ottoman army
thus preventing further autumn and expansion into Europe forever.
There is debate concerning the point of the wings on the armor.
A large part of it was likely a part of psychological warfare.
Not only were they a formidable site,
especially when they're charging toward you,
but they clap together and we're very loud,
which might have intimidated enemy forces and scared their horses and also
perhaps made their forest to look larger.
They may have even offer protection from enemies,
swords or lasso is and deaf in their own horses to the intimidation efforts of
the enemy.
Speaking of which,
whose Aras horses were also specially bred for speed,
strength,
and endurance known sometimes as tarpon selling such a horse to someone outside
of the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth warranted the death penalty along with the
wings and the horses that whose Aras were.
As I said,
well armed and armored,
they often carried a lance to swords,
two pistols and an ax or a Warhammer.
Even the armor was often light in order for them to be flexible and they often
wore animal pelts.
The primary tactic of the whose Aras was to charge the enemy lines then fall
back and repeat the charge as was necessary until the enemy routed.
They would even typically have spare Lance's in the supply wagons to repeat such
charges.
The Polish wing to Zara's would fight through the 18th century until they were
officially disbanded in 1776 when their duties and roles and combat were
replaced by a new force of light cavalry known as lawns,
as heavy cavalry became easier to challenge with the greater effectiveness of
infantry.
Lighter cavalry were more favors than the wing desires and thus they were
retired.
Yet to this day,
they remain icons of Poland and its history as they dominated many battlefields
of eastern and central Europe for over two centuries.
For more videos like this and videos on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire of learning and subscribed.
Thank you for watching.